i'm a little wonton
living my best life
[Music]
hello i'm hannah hart and welcome back
to edible history the show that studies
the history of edible things that we
love like wontons
i love wontons especially wonton soup
the broth is so flavorful and the
wontons are so delicate when i'm sick i
don't want a chicken noodle soup i want
wonton soup but i hardly know anything
about it where did the wonton come from
and why is it here what's the difference
between a wonton and a dumpling to find
out i'm asking tommy wong executive chef
at trey un first things first i have a
very basic wonton question what's the
difference between a wonton and a
dumpling dumplings they're shaped
different they start off round and
they're a little thicker the wontons are
square a little thinner made usually
made with egg and flour so you have this
is a fast food version where they just
pinch it and this is a little more fancy
version where it's shaped like a gold or
silver nugget from the old currency our
purposes here today are to try and find
the oldest
recipes for certain dishes the montana
goes back you know as far back as the
han dynasty one ton is canned from the
southern part of china the southern
region one is cloud ton is swallow he's
swallowing a clown so the wonton i've
only ever actually had it like alongside
wonton soup is that the traditional way
it's served tons can be served fry with
soup or with just a sauce all of this
has been so educational and nothing
makes me hungrier than a good learning
so this is where the magic happens okay
i'm sorry it's it's hard to do this when
i'm being watched is it intentional that
they're all just facing me could they
just look the other way
to make the broth we have to boil water
so that's the easy part and on so the
broth is pretty basic it's uh water salt
and
this guy
this is an emotional
roadblock oh beautiful a nice rolling
boil just what we needed okay all right
vaderchi
see on the flip side
oh they're turning red right away
we got a crabs in the pot now we're just
gonna let them simmer for you know hours
and hours and hours so i'll just hang
out
has anybody uh
got some cards
while our broth simmers for hours and
hours we're going to move on to making
the wonton skin the old recipe i have
says one catty of flower
feel like a golf caddy you think i don't
know what a caddy is good news is i do
have
a dictionary oh wow look at all these
words i didn't know chamonix a mountain
valley in eastern france cascara a
buckthorn catty
a weight equal to about one and a half
pounds now that we've determined a caddy
is one and a half pounds i'll use my
handy dandy ye old scale
okay so
that scoop is um
it's gonna take us a minute we might
want to speed this up
[Music]
two pounds
[Music]
riveting content we have achieved
exactly a pound and a half of flour and
three tenths of an ounce of salt oh my
god do i have to weigh that again
it's probably like that much salt
add a little water
probably like yay making wonton skins
that's a labor of love right there okay
here we
go our 700 year old recipe specifically
says to knead the dough 100 times so
count along with me
[Music]
i'll tell you this takes a
one ton of effort
i think we're getting pretty close we're
gonna use the patented finger poke test
to see if there's a little bit of
buoyancy in this bread baby
we have achieved our wonton dough and
now we're actually going to take this
dough and make it into skids so we're
going to take our dough break it off
into little balls
smaller balls
do you feel like a wonton yet since i
don't have 700 years of experience we're
gonna just test this guy out and see if
this is gonna be about the right size a
little sprinkle of flour
that's pretty thin that's skin baby
how do we make it into a square i guess
we just cut it into a square
[Music]
that's not a square
oh look
we can try again let's really delicately
cut a square
[Music]
oh thank god
we've got our first wonton skin done
we're gonna put it on this plate to the
side we're gonna sprinkle a little on
top so that way the next time we place a
skin on top they don't all stick
together and then hannah doesn't just
quit and walk off set let's keep going
so i've made six wonton skins which is
enough for six wontons which is enough
for one bowl of soup which is enough for
one little henna so we're gonna save the
rest of our dough and move on to our
filling
[Music]
for our filling we're gonna be using
green onion and crab meat next we're
moving on to the crab meat now we are
using specifically only the claw because
that's what it says i gotta tell you
guys making dumplings from scratch is
not all it's cracked up to be
oh look at that crab meat oh my god i'm
actually salivating i would just eat
these right now it's pretty amazing to
think that what we're doing right now is
a recipe that's been made for about 700
years humans have been eating things a
long time
oh
she did it now it is time to wash my
hands forever oh wait let's finish
making the filling first we're gonna
take our crab meat and then we're gonna
add what seems to be the right amount of
green onion you know
[Music]
filling done now on to the ultra fun
part which is actually making our little
wontons
now we finally get to assemble our
wontons i've been looking forward to
this all day long so i've actually made
dumplings before and what i learned in
that experience is that the fold is
crucial to keeping the filling inside so
i imagine that when working with wontons
it's probably pretty similar so our
beautiful precious freshly made wonton
skins
place in your left hand cradle it like a
baby next we're going to take a small
amount of filling we're going to place a
little in the corner i bet the first
wontons like the first pancake we're
folding
we're rolling gonna pinch it now it
looks like a croissant and here we go we
have our little flat hat and then we
pinch and fold together and that is my
first attempt at a wonton
wow we've got room for improvement guys
that's why we have five more skins to go
it does have a different folding
technique than modern day wontons you
might be wondering hannah why aren't you
dabbing the edges with water it doesn't
say use water it says hold in left hand
fold fold fold happy day
hello dolly that is a pretty good
looking wonton
all right now we've got our six little
wontons our broth is almost done so last
step is to just assemble the soup and
then eat it
we're on the home stretch of making our
700 year old wonton soup so now let's
check on how our broth is doing
[Music]
oh god that smells like boiled crab so
i'm just gonna go ahead and strain it
all out now
big boys
it looks like the bottom of the ocean
whew
wish you guys could be here to fully
experience it with all your senses as i
am
right now since i'm waking wontons for
won i am going to swap this pot out for
a smaller pot and now it is time to say
goodbye to our little crappy friends who
are off to have another adventure oh yum
look at that crab water you guys want to
see a magic trick behold a simple pot of
boiled crab water add a little salt and
now it's broth i'm going to take some of
the broth ladle into this smaller pot
and boil my wontons in here
now we have our broth at a nice healthy
boil so let's add our wontons are you
ready for your final destination
they're even prettier than i remember
here we go
i feel so proud oh what just making 700
year old wonton soup from scratch why
what are you up to
now we're gonna wait about two or three
minutes as the broth comes to another
boil with the wontons and the wontons
cook fully through so talk to a loved
one really fast it's wild to think that
making this wonton soup took so much
effort even including modern
conveniences could you imagine doing all
this and having to stoke a fire to keep
a rolling boil
awesome all of our wontons are floating
so now it's time to serve the soup and
give it a taste
[Music]
and now the moment of truth
our 700 year old wonton soup how did it
turn out
[Music]
[Music]
we totally made wonton soup it was a
little doughy probably could have used a
thinner skin that's my note that crab
flavor really
really comes through but honestly the
taste of the crab the salt the texture
of the wonton it really does all come
together we did it this is a
hole-in-one don now i'm gonna make this
soup a thing of the past
get it by eating it
that's all folks i'm hannah hart and
this has been edible history
you